[Music]
what up guys this goes on here and first
and foremost I wanna thank you guys for
almost 30,000 subscribers how quickly
we've been growing lately is
mind-blowing once again thanks so much
guys if you do not know already in the
last video I told you guys that we were
doing a poll for what the next video
should be and you guys decided that we
should do a video about the ninth titan
shifter and here we are now even before
this poll this video was insanely
requested and I even asked you guys who
/ what you thought the ninth titan was
in my founding titan explain video so
I'll be drawing on your ideas here too
as we try to figure out who the ninth
and final type of shifter is if you
haven't already be sure to subscribe
because we have a lot of attack on Titan
videos on this channel already and many
more on the way also there will be manga
spoilers in this video we need all the
evidence we can get if we're going to
crack this mystery so if you haven't
read the manga proceed with extreme
caution now if you're psyched and ready
to go smash that like button and let's
do this as you already know Ahmir Fritz
aka the founding Titan was the first to
gain the Titan power
she died thirteen years after receiving
that power and her power was split into
nine different Titan powers most manga
readers thought that we already knew
what the nine Titan powers were the
colossal Titan also referred to as the
Colossus Titan the armored Titan the
attack Titan also referred to as the
rogue Titan the female Titan the Beast
Titan the dancing Titan Cartman also
referred to as the quadrupedal Titan the
jaw Titan and finally the most powerful
one the founding Titan also referred to
as the coordinate which currently lies
mostly dormant in Harran however this
was revealed to be incorrect when people
realized that gal yds jaw Titan power
was actually one of the same as a
mirrors dancing Titan so in reality even
though people thought they were
different
yamir actually had the power of the jaw
Titan that currently dwells within Porco
Galliard thus we only know of a Titan
powers null which means there's one out
there yet to be revealed this has led to
theories about who the next item shifter
could be and what the power of the final
Titan could be
this is exactly what this video is about
we're going to be looking at the
theories and figuring out which ones are
less or more likely as always guys feel
free to share your thoughts about the
ninth titans identity and unique powers
in the comment section below now we know
that after the great titan war Marlay
had seven out of nine titan powers in
their control these powers were the
beast Titan inherited by Zeke the
colossal Titan inherited by battled the
armored Titan inherited by Reiner the
female Titan inherited by a me the
drawtite inherited by Marcel and later
by Galliard Cartman inherited by Peake
and the final one is most likely the
attack Titan which was stolen by the LD
inspiring Kruger aka the owl and passed
on to Grisha and then to Aaron
that leaves the founding Titan in
another unknown Titan power we know that
the founding Titan was in the possession
of King fritz or the 145th King when he
moved the capital of aldea from the
continent to the island of parody's
these aliens who migrated must have
taken the ninth titan power to the
island of parodies so whoever has the
titan power is most likely inside the
walls
unless someone within the walls who had
that power died because of the Emir's
curse before they got the chance to pass
it on in that case the power would go to
a random LDN baby who could be on the
continent or on the island theoretically
they can be anywhere and still inherent
to power as long as they have LD in
blood if that were the case then the
power could literally pop up anywhere
but I still think that it is most likely
someone within the wall now you may be
thinking that it cannot be any of the
characters we know because they are all
older than 13 years old and would have
died from Ymir's Kurtz but that's not
necessarily the case let's take a look
at the Ackermann clan who are the
byproducts of titan science so chances
are that their powers work similarly to
that of Titan shifters all acronyms have
the potential to be amazing warriors and
killing machines but they need to awaken
to these powers first Nika saw weekend
after her parents died and she needed to
save Eren that's when her hand stopped
shaking and she knew exactly what to do
all Ackerman's if they wish to harness
their full power must go through this
awakening they are not simply born as
killing machine
furthermore yamir fritz did not die at
the age of 13 but as Erin points out she
died 13 years after first awakening to
her powers so what does all this mean
well it means that one of our characters
that we have already been introduced to
might have the final type of power
resting inside them but it has yet to be
awakened
thus Ymir's curse has not taken effect
yet and will not until the powers are
activated and if we can take any clues
from how the Ackermann awakening works
we might see the power awaken in a time
of great emotional stress so now we see
how one of our current main characters
could potentially have the ninth titan
power within them but who is it and what
kind of Titan power could it be some of
you have speculated that it could be
Mikasa and although I know that a lot of
you want to see me cuz I become a Titan
it's highly unlikely in my opinion we
know that people must be LD aims to
become Titans and we know that the
acronym bloodline and the Asian
bloodline are separate from the LDN
bloodline so that probably would not
work some of you thought that it could
be Levi although Levi is already
stronger than most Titans as he is that
theory is plausible we recently learned
in the manga that Ryan's father was a
Marlon soldier thus he is only part ldm
on his mother's side yet we know that he
can inherit a Titan power the armored
Titan power to be specific therefore
people that are part LD and can inherit
the Titan power even if the other part
of them the Marlon part in Ryan's case
would not otherwise be affected by Titan
serum as we know Levi's mother is an
acronym aka from an unaffected bloodline
but we do not know what Levi's father
was Levi's mother worked as a prostitute
in the underground city and was
impregnated by one of her clients
considering that the island of paradise
consists mainly of LD ins it is more
than likely that Levi's father was an
Lda so yes it is possible that Levi has
the nine Titan power within him however
like I said Levi is already so strong
and so cool without Titan powers that I
personally don't see a point in making
him into a Titan II but he is the most
popular character an attack on Titan and
Hajime isayama does
on two wishes of his fans sometimes so
who knows it is possible that some of
you may get your wish something that I
did speculate before was that possibly
the royal family did figure out a way to
infuse the power of the nine Titan into
the acraman bloodline thus giving them
Titan like powers even if they cannot
transform into actual Titans building on
this idea John writes as it is said on
your other video the Ackerman's are the
bypass product of Titan science maybe
the ninth Titan ability lives within
captain Levi and Mikasa one of the
proofs is that Myka so surpassed four of
the known typing shifters in the
animated series she is the top one of
the 104th Cadet Corps and also may be
the main purpose of the ninth Titan
ability is to stop the rest of the a
Titan powers it is said in the manga
that Levi defeated the most powerful
Titan which is of these Titan may be the
main purpose of the ninth Titan ability
is to prevent all the other a Titan
abilities from abusing their power I
definitely still think this could be a
possibility and I think it would be a
creative way for ISA Amma to incorporate
the nine Titan power into the story let
me know what you guys think about this
one
even though it would not be quite as
glamorous as a brand new Titan with a
brand new set of abilities and now the
person who in my opinion is the most
likely to be in possession of the ninth
and final time power is historia
historian was always portrayed as
extremely special even among people of
royal blood the LD ins believed that
yamir was a goddess and historia has
been referred to as a goddess on several
occasions suggesting that she might
possibly have some of yamir Fritz's
powers inside her there just seems to be
so much for shying around her character
that it's almost impossible to ignore it
her name is even a reference to history
and Ymir Fritz is the single most
important historical figure and
happening within the attack on Titan
world I would not be surprised at all if
it is through historia that we learn
more about the mysterious history of
yamir fritz then of course there's the
attack on titan ova that cannot go
unmentioned and serves as a good
transition into the possible hidden
power that the ninth titan might possess
in the comedic OVA which compiles a
bunch of Yama's fake or joke
reviews that he likes to draw at the end
of his manga chapters we see historia
among the hundred fourth training corps
members transform into a Titan but she
is completely unlike the others or any
other Titan we've ever seen she has
wings and an angel light presence her
eyes begin to glow and the colorful aura
that emanates from her blows the
commander away now yes this does seem
too obvious and like a possible red
herring
but Issei Yama has never really been one
for subtle foreshadowing at the very
least we know that Ishiyama is once more
signaling historian out of special and
we know that the thought of winged Titan
historia has entered his head to all
those who say it won't happen just
because he added it in this joke preview
or OVA I'll just point to the fact that
Arman also turns into a Titan in this
preview and that didn't stop me syama
from having it happen in the actual
manga so yeah I really do think there's
a good chance that it will be historia
even if the Titan doesn't look exactly
like the one in the preview now let's
talk about the wings what will be the
power of this final Titan will it be
flight most of you theorized and hoped
that it would be a flying wing Titan I
think that this is definitely a
possibility again we've had heavy
foreshadowing to indicate this the manga
previews we just discussed show that the
idea of a winged Titan is something that
has definitely crossed ISA Alma's mind
let's also not overlook all of the bird
imagery that has been so prevalent in
attack on Titan I mean the coat of arms
for the survey Corps probably the most
identifiable symbol in the whole anime
is a pair of wings and on top of all
that we got chapter 93 of the manga in
which a male in general speaks about how
they could really use a flying Titan and
asks whether there are any Titans will
wings knowing Hajime isayama given these
clues it's definitely possible that we
could in fact get a winged Titan and
this may well be historian some of you
who really like this winged Titan theory
even speculated that the ninth Titan
shifter could be falco who had not yet
awakened to his power his name which
means hawk or a falcon definitely points
to that possibility so you guys may be
onto something there also shout out to
hungry drove
who would like to see an aquatic Titan
anyways guys those are my thoughts on
the ninth and final type of shifter make
sure to let me know what you guys think
of these theories and if you have any
others I really loved reading about all
of your theories and ideas so thanks so
much for sharing if you like this video
be sure to smash that like button and
subscribe for more attack on Titan
videos until next time see us space
cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]